GENE'S BEST FRIEND
WAS ABSURD,
AND HE PROPOSED AN INTERESTING,
IF UNORTHODOX, WAY
TO SETTLE THE ISSUE.
- YOU KNOW, BACK IN BASIC,
WE HAD A SAYING.
"DON'T TALK THE TALK
IF YOU CAN'T WALK THE WALK."
- MEANING?
- I'M CHALLENGING YOU
TO A FRIEND-OFF.
- WHAT IS THAT?
- WE WILL TRY TO OUT-FRIEND
EACH OTHER WITH GENE
UNTIL ONE GUY CAN'T FRIEND
ANYMORE, AND THEN HE GOES,
FOR GOOD.
- OKAY.
YOU'RE ON.
I CAN OUT-FRIEND YOU ANY DAY.
- HEY, GUYS, CAN YOU REMIND ME
TO GET TOILET PAPER
ON THE WAY HOME?
- YES, ABSOLUTELY.
IN FACT, I WILL SET
AN ALARM ON MY PHONE
TO REMIND ME TO REMIND YOU
TO GET TOILET PAPER.
- I'LL GET YOU ENOUGH
TOILET PAPER TO LAST 100 YEARS.
- I DON'T KNOW
WHERE YOU'RE GONNA KEEP
ALL THAT TOILET PAPER.
SO I POURED IT ON, FRIENDING
AS HARD AS I COULD FRIEND.
HEY, GUYS!
[chuckles]
HAPPY BIRTHDAY, MY FRIEND.
- OH, MY BIRTHDAY
WAS TWO MONTHS AGO, FORREST.
- HOP ON, MY FRIEND.
- OH, MY--
THIS IS BEAUTIFUL, FORREST.
- IT IS.
YOU KNOW, THIS IS WHAT
BEST FRIENDS DO.
- YEAH.
- THAT'S REALLY NICE,
BUT YOU GOT TO BE CAREFUL
WITH THESE THINGS.
I MEAN, I'VE BEEN
READING ABOUT 'EM,
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
RUNNING OVER THEIR KIDS.
- YEAH, WELL--
- KID LOST PART OF HIS FACE.
- I-I'VE BEEN READING
ABOUT 'EM TOO.
THEY SAID IT WAS NO BIG DEAL.
WHAT THEY'RE DOING
WITH FACES THESE DAYS--
THEY TAKE SOMEBODY'S FACE, AND
THEY PUT IT ON SOMEBODY ELSE,
SO THEY GET
THIS FACIAL RECONSTRUCTION.
I'M NOT SAYING
IT'S GONNA HAPPEN.
- RIGHT.
- I DON'T THINK YOU'RE GONNA
RUN OVER CLAYTON'S FACE
OR HE'S GONNA LOSE
ANY OF HIS FACE.
BUT I'M SAYING IF IT DID HAPPEN,
THEY'VE GOT THE SCIENCE NOW--
BUT CARLOS PROVED
TO BE A WORTHY ADVERSARY.
THE BEST PLACE IN TOWN.
- OH, MY GOD.
WHAT IS THAT
IN THE BACKYARD?
- OH, YOU'RE HERE.
- WHAT IS THAT?
- WAIT A SECOND.
ISN'T THAT THE NEW GRILL
THAT I JUST GOT YOU
THAT YOU SHOULD BE MAKING
BURGERS ON RIGHT NOW?
COME ON.
- CARLOS! YOU ARE AWESOME!
- BURGERS?
- DON'T TOUCH IT!
I WANT TO TOUCH IT.
HEY, MAN,
THIS THING'S AWESOME.
- WELL, IT'S STAINLESS STEEL.
IT'S GONNA LAST 100 YEARS.
- THAT'S A LONG TIME
TO EAT FLAVORLESS MEAT.
YOU KNOW, CHARCOAL GRILLS HAVE
MORE OF A SMOKY TASTE, I FIND.
- OH, HEY, SUZANNE.
- SUZANNE.
HEY, COME JOIN US FOR A BURGER.
- NO, THANK YOU.
- OH. YOU GOT PLANS?
- NOPE.
- SO FAR, SPENDING TIME
WITH GENE HADN'T DONE ANYTHING
TO IMPROVE MY RELATIONSHIP
WITH SUZANNE.
SHE'S ALWAYS GOT
SOMETHING GOING ON.
THANKS, GENE.
BUT I WAS NOT ABOUT TO GIVE UP.